just naked outside the store she's
rubbing herself all across the windows
everyone is just staring at her and
you're just like what do you do hi my
name is Brian well we know I am a former
Apple employee hi my name is David I am
a former Apple store employee about
three years
hi I'm my name is glory and I currently
work at Apple and I have been for like
the last year or so and today we're
gonna be sharing our horror stories
so I used to work at the store back in
Miami and we had a lot of people from
fazil Colombia or South America Central
America that would come and buy phones
in bulk so one time this customer came
in he had his family and he bought five
or six iPhones at one time as they
usually do and they paid with hundreds
now we have these pens and our registers
that obviously we used to check but for
some reason it cleared once the end of
the day came and you know they start
counting the money they nose out in the
back the numbers were off and it came
back as fake so then I was you know
getting in trouble and I said I did
everything correct we double-checked
that everybody count today it was good
so that happened once and I believe it
happened to somebody else as well wasn't
fun wasn't a good experience we did end
up finding out who it was cuz I've done
it before but I'm glad that was handled
and taken care of I guess the more of
the story would be just don't use fake
money at all so this was definitely one
of my most uncomfortable retail
experiences at Apple it was a very slow
day at the store and this gentleman
comes over to me and he goes hey I have
some questions about the iPads could you
help me out so I go to the iPad table I
go directly to like the 12.9 Pro like a
really big one I had a real sense that
something was kind of like off because
if you've ever been an Apple store all
the screens on the devices how big a
screen saver that's always going off on
them but the whole table of iPads all
the screens were like black telly this
is kind of weird so I'm like describing
the iPad to him and I go and I just like
press the home button and there was a
human being of the female persuasion and
it was a photograph of her from like
this up or perspective one of these like
upside down peace signs like on her
shenanigans and so it was just that
right across the screen and so I kind of
like scrambled to reach up to hit the
power off button and the man kind of
looked at me a little horrified and I
was like apologizing to him I was like
let's move on so we move over to like
the opposite corner turn on that one
same thing I was like this whole table
it's been raped I'm being bamboozled
right now so I turn it off and I was
like maybe we would
I was so uncomfortable that entire
interaction after that I was like sir I
think it's best if you leave and I go to
the back and cry and we just call this
one a day did the customer end up buying
anything he left
yikes yeah ended up leaving with an iPad
case and he decided to order the iPad
online so the sale was made just in a
different way and I think I know who it
was - there was like this like bratty
teenager with like a skateboard like in
the corner he was just like pretending
to like use the headphones so if I ever
catch you I don't work at Apple anymore
so I'm coming for you can't say that
that's kidding so my store is actually
really really really big and there's a
huge glass wall on the entrance a lot of
transient homeless community comes in
out of the store they you know use our
computers and then leave when they can
and sometimes because they are in the
store a lot some people are a little
crazy and this is a story about this one
crazy lady she has been in the store a
few times so no one like paid attention
to her but she comes in the store and
she's like oh Apple has been hacking my
account for the last five years and
whenever someone comes in and says that
they're automatically crazy because
Apple doesn't really care about your
account and so in this time she asks
gates a little bit and starts yelling
really crazy profanities and then all of
a sudden she starts spitting on one of
our computers so security then basically
grabbed her because she was like
fighting them and they kicked her out of
the store and so it kind of dies down a
little bit and so then she's outside
again and you can hear her screaming
she's causing a lot of attention to her
outside of the store and mind you huge
glass building so we all can see here
and then all of a sudden this woman
starts stripping this woman start taking
off all of her clothes and now she is
but ass naked and everyone is just
staring at her and you're just like what
did you do what do you do in the
situation so the managers like frantic
freaking out and they called the cops
and then the cops come and she's still
fighting them
and the arrest her and then it's like
nothing ever happened and that's it it
was like within the first few months I
started working there so that was like
my real introduction to working at Apple
to hear anything about her afterwards no
she just disappeared from dinner after
that it was business as normal no one
ever heard from her ever again
who knows where she could be no idea she
could be I don't know